[Music] Do your
best to re-weaponize humanity. You're
still going to survive. You should
definitely take better care of yourself. You must have been worried,
hunka is a life-threatening job. The
only thing you need to do to survive is to stay sick and
die.  I don't want to die after a new awakening,
haven't I? I've got my equipment
ready, I've done what I need to do, and I'm confident in my ability to run away. Now, let's go
[music] I'm
not going to die easily, so you guys should
hang in there too.  Let's fight passionately and passionately, it's the best we can do If we become
strong enough, we'll be able to escape this life where we've been laughed at for so long.  It would be a
lie to say that.If I give up,
that's the end.I'll level up even more and get everything
back.I'm growing in a place like this
[music]
What is that?
Well, let's get started,
too.For that time, Suha Street
is that guy.  The hunter I am is the
true beginning of being called a hunter.I
am constantly leveling up.OG